tell us a little bit about how long
you've worked together and how long
you've danced together in two thousand I
saw a little clip on the news of Pierre
teaching some kids in the Bronx and I
tracked him down and I optioned his
rights which became a movie called take
the lead starring Antonio Banderas and
that was the story of when pierre went
into the public schools of New York to
teach inner-city kids to ballroom dance
in 1994 now if you remember in 1994
ballroom dancing was not cool there was
no dancing with the stars and they
thought he was insane it was really
difficult for him but against all odds
he started with 30 reluctant kids and
he's now taught over 400 thousand kids
the system amazing right so knowing the
power of the program in the unbelievable
power of Pierre when he called to say he
was going to fulfill his lifelong dream
I said I'm going with you so now we get
to the point where you were you go to
Java how do you begin to find schools
how do you begin to get anybody
interested in doing this I felt that I
did some good with the children in New
York City I used to be very shy very
timid after with etc it did a lot of
good for me and being half palestinian i
thought i would like to give a gift of
dance to the children i had a woman by
the name of melee shahe Flavie who had
seen another film of our program dancing
classrooms called mad hot ballroom so
she came and visited me and said like
I'd like to take the program to Israel I
said yes okay lovely but only if I could
bring the two communities the Arabs and
the Jews do dance together her eyes
opened her ears opened wider and we
became friends and then when it was the
right time she's the one that helped
find the five schools actually there
were two other schools that we tried
Arab schools that could not handle it so
they said no but we had five schools and
I was started but I also have to say
that there was one Arab father yeah who
was dead against the idea his daughter
was not going to be in the program so we
sent Piron to talk to him
and at the end of the conversation
because Pierre could show him all of the
statistics and the success stories of
the New York schools and how it changes
the kids it's not just ballroom dance it
changes them academically it teaches
them life skills they learn confidence
self-esteem etiquette self respect
respect for your partner one doesn't
preclude the other but most importantly
they do better academically and this
father wanted his kid to have as good a
chance as any of the other kids so he
came on board he have turned around and
then he did PR for us and got all the
other parents to bring their kids in
bramble it's one thing to bring kids
together in New York City school but
when you have Muslims who have been
taught and you who are not to dance with
the opposite sex you couldn't have done
this for instance with an Orthodox
Jewish school they would not dance
together so how is it to convince
somebody that it is okay even though all
of their cultural training is against
that you are asking them to go against
their training what saved the day is
that I speak Arabic but i think the
arabic word is hudspeth hahaha love it
first I lived at Brooklyn also the
International work but I speak Arabic
with the Palestinian accent and so it's
not an Iraqi accent or a syrian accent
and that was the local dialect there you
know and that I bill I know this is what
helped my big thing is for the
Palestinian Israeli communities is that
I wanted them to be have a choice to be
on the world stage this more the world
is getting smaller and if you can stand
up straighter by having to dance in a
correct way you have to stand straight
these are muscular memories that stay
with you for life and then you go and
shake hands with a person you're going
to travel and this is the International
universal stage that I would like them
to be a part of and the Jewish people
didn't read they were reluctant to
having their children dance with the
Arabs because it's a lower class for
them but somehow again if we say doing
OLS school doing better at school and
and for a child once you come there you
really can't give up on them because
scar them for life and it was it was I
mean they were what were they doing
spitting at each other at the beginning
piggy each other there are 10 years old
and they hate each other they don't even
know why I mean we have we don't have
the same problems in New York City but
and whatever we are but all of the
children that that age cover and the
code is good is good is you know
regardless right but the truth is racism
segregation and Prejudice are global
issues you're in Minnesota there in the
Bronx and there in Jaffa this was an
extreme case so we could dramatize me
Diane you were telling me that all of
the children have seen this now talk
people about that so we opened the film
and Tribeca and then we went immediately
the next week to open the film we were
the opening night film in dock Aviv
which was in the port of Tel Aviv it's a
documentary film festival yes in in Tel
Aviv and so we had all the kids come see
the film and none of them had seen it
and we were really nervous because you
know it's really personable personal to
show footage of yourself in you know the
therapists office and all the kids
hating you and we were so nervous for
for nor and you know Louis being the
sperm baby I mean you know there's all
this personal information so we SAT with
them and yeah we were you know and
helping them to sort of process it and I
don't know that they really got it but
then the next day nor was walking down
the street in Jaffa and everybody came
up to her and said oh my god you were
incredible in the movie so she became
like a mini movie star and she's really
proud of it and you know I think they
really they love it now